Sean, happy holidays. Happy holidays to you, Will. And happy holidays to all of our listeners here at SmartList. Happy holidays to all of our listeners of SmartList. The podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and I bring on a surprise guest every week while surprised to the other two. And then we just, there is no format. If you're expecting me to roll out a format, there is none.
Sean，节快乐。也祝你节日快乐，威尔。祝我们SmartLess的所有听众节日快乐。祝我们SmartLess的所有听众节日快乐。这个播客节目由杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯和我共同主持，我们每周都会请来一位惊喜嘉宾，而其他两人事先并不知道。然后我们就会——没有任何环节。如果你期待我设计什么环节，那根本没有。
We just kind of talk until it's done. So all right, it's an all new episode of SmartList. Let's go. Smart. Wireless. Smart. Wireless. Smart.
我们就是随便聊到结束为止。好了，这是一期全新的SmartLess节目。我们走吧。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Wireless. Smart. Wireless. What do you got in the thermos today, Jason? Yeah, what is in the thermos? It's more, more electrolytes. But what about my super tacky, um, oh Dodgers. Oh Dodgers.
Less。Smart。Less。杰森，你今天保温杯里装的是什么？对啊，保温杯里装的是什么？又是电解质水。不过我这个超俗气的，哦，道奇队的帽子。哦，道奇队的。
Was that a father's day gift? This is like this kind of thing you buy at a sporting good checkout line. Do you wear a new balance as well? Sorry, Sean, is new balance not cool? No, I think new balance, by the way, I own new balance with the extra cushion one. Oh my God. Oh my God. He has new balance.
那是父亲节礼物吗？这感觉就像你在体育用品店结账排队时顺手买的东西。你平时也穿纽巴伦（New Balance）的鞋吗？抱歉，肖恩，纽巴伦现在不时髦吗？不，我觉得纽巴伦，顺便说一句，我也有一双带额外气垫的。天哪。天哪。他居然穿纽巴伦。
He does. The person does. Yeah. He's got new balance. By the way, so do I. They're very comfortable. In most days, if Jason walked by, you knew you didn't know he was an actor. If I didn't know he was an actor and somebody said, guess that guy's profession, I'd say
他确实穿。这人还真穿。对啊。他穿着纽巴伦。顺便说一句，我也穿。这鞋非常舒服。大多数时候，如果杰森从你旁边走过，你绝对看不出他是个演员。如果我不知道他是个演员，而有人让我猜这家伙的职业，我会说
male nurse. Yep. For sure. In most days. What about you drinking Diet Coke at, how old are you, 65? Dude. Why would you do that? I just turned 50.
男护士。对。绝对是。大多数时候。那你呢，居然在喝健怡可乐，你多大了，65岁？老兄。你为什么会喝那个？我才刚满50岁。
You know that. Sean, what are you, you're drinking, it's just. Water all the time. I don't have electrolyte. And what's the university that you're, you're pimping on your shirt? Uh, University of California. California. California.
你知道的。肖恩，你呢，你一直在喝的，就是。水。我没有喝电解质水。那你衣服上打广告的那个大学是哪个？加州大学。加州。加州。
I guess. Did you spill some cranberry juice on yourself at the airport and you needed a new t-shirt just for the trip, so you just ducked into the Hudson news. Look, I couldn't get the cranberry down fast enough. Do you think he drinks cranberry juice because of yeast infections? Yes. No, it's bladder infections. Isn't it supposed to be for bladder infections?
我猜的。是不是你在机场不小心把蔓越莓汁洒在身上了，旅行急需一件新T恤，所以直接扎进了哈德逊新闻书店？听着，我当时根本来不及把蔓越莓汁咽下去。你觉得他喝蔓越莓汁是因为有尿路感染吗？是的。不对，是膀胱感染。这不就是治膀胱感染的吗？
Cleans your kidneys out. Bladder infections. Bladder infections. Yeah. No, but I clean my kidney. Have you guys ever had a kidney stone? I'm going to open up every episode with an ailment I have. No, but I do hear that that's from dehydration.
清肾的。膀胱感染。膀胱感染。对。不对，我这是在清肾。你们得过肾结石吗？我以后每一期节目都要以我身上的某种病痛开头。没有，不过我听说那是因为脱水造成的。
And so that's why I drink a lot of electrolytes. That's right. That, by the way, that's really good because you get it like spinach. It all has to do with, um, I can't remember, I can't remember what it's called. Oh, you can't remember? Great story. Definitely make us wait as you try to remember. But no, if you guys have never had a kidney stone, it's, it's like, I hear it's a worst
所以这就是为什么我喝很多电解质水。没错。那个，顺便说一句，真的很管用，因为吃菠菜之类的东西会得这病。这和，嗯，我想不起来了，我想不起来它叫什么了。哦，你想不起来了？好棒的故事。绝对让我们一边等你回忆一边干着急。不过说真的，如果你们没得过肾结石，那感觉，我听说那是世上最
thing. Peeing out a baby. I can't wait to get back to this. Now listen. Sure. I don't know what to say about her a special guest because I'm about to start with an apology. I want to have you.
像生孩子一样的痛。我等不及要回到正题了。听好了。当然。我不知道该怎么介绍这位特别的嘉宾，因为我要先道个歉。我想请你出来。
I'm going to apologize. I apologize. This person, um, I am so in awe of this person. I'm very starstruck and dumbfounded. It's not money there, but boy, you're going to be embarrassed when Vernon shows up on the show. I owe him a huge apology. Oh, Justin, Vernon, I did a bit that was just had nothing to do with him or his band.
我要道歉。我道歉。这个人，嗯，我对这个人佩服得五体投地。我感到非常震惊和目瞪口呆。这倒不是钱的问题，不过，当弗农（Vernon）出现在节目里时，你可就尴尬了。我欠他一个巨大的道歉。哦，贾斯汀·弗农（Justin Vernon），我以前开过一个玩笑，跟他的乐队或他本人一点关系都没有。
So this person, I was just in a mood. This person has won so many accolades in their career and is just piling them on. This person has, and I'm, again, I'm just, I don't know where to start. I'm, I'm giddy. This person has been named FIFA soccer player of the year times has won the ball on door has won, I think two world cups. This person is a complete badass is a social activist is the coolest person and I'm so excited.
所以这个人，我当时心情不太好。这人在职业生涯中赢得了无数的荣誉，而且还在不断刷新纪录。这个人，我再次声明，我不知道该从哪里开始。我太兴奋了。这个人曾多次被评为国际足联世界足球小姐（FIFA soccer player of the year），赢得过金球奖，还赢得过好像两届世界杯。这个人绝对是个狠角色，是一位社会活动家，是最酷的人，我太兴奋了。
I've, yes. Let me say hello to Oh, Megan Rapinoe. Nice. Oh my gosh. I've always wanted to meet you. Good morning. I'm such a huge fan. Hi there.
我已经。让我跟她打个招呼，哦，梅根·拉皮诺埃（Megan Rapinoe）。太棒了。天哪。我一直想见你。早上好。我是你的超级大粉丝。你好啊。
Good morning. I've been trying to be quiet over here, but I'm dying at everything. Well, to Jason's point, we apologize for the, the rambling up at top. It's definitely we're going to get back to, to Sean's passing the stone. Oh, we can't wait, Sean. Listener, I wish you could see how Megan has kindly matched her hair color to her tie dye shirt. It is, it is something that that is looking great.
早上好。我本来想在旁边保持安静的，但我快笑死了。好吧，就像杰森说的，我们为开头那些东拉西扯道歉。我们待会儿肯定会回到肖恩的肾结石话题上的。哦，我们迫不及待了，肖恩。听众朋友们，我要是能让你们看到梅根如何巧妙地将她头发的颜色与她那件扎染衬衫相搭配就好了。真的，真的，看起来棒极了。
Look at that. I had a big pod today. So I had to get it. I was matching my, I hope that big pod goes well. It must be after ours, but Megan so great to meet you. I'm so, first of all, I want to say, and this is going to date the day that we, we recorded this, but I want to say, are you excited because one of your old teams, Leon is playing in the semi-final.
看那个。我今天有个很大的播客要录。所以我得准备一下。我得搭配一下我的，希望那个大播客录得顺利。那肯定是在我们录完之后，不过梅根，很高兴见到你。首先，我想说，这可能会暴露我们录制这期节目的日期，但我还是想问，你现在很兴奋吗，因为你的老东家里昂队正在踢半决赛。
The men's squad is playing the semi-final against Byron Munich today. Is that something that you were, you watch, are you, do you watch any of the Champions League? The dudes? Yeah. I'm definitely following the Champions League. I missed the game yesterday. I don't know what happened.
男足今天正在踢对阵拜仁慕尼黑的半决赛。这是你会关注的比赛吗，你会看欧冠吗？男足的？对。我绝对有关注欧冠。我昨天错过那场比赛了。我不知道发生什么事了。
I don't know where I was. I just blanked on it. I saw the Barcelona disaster. That was really something to watch at the highest level of international soccer. I was like, Oh God. But I'm a big fan of Leon. Obviously I played there and, you know, friends with, or friendly, at least with the president there, Jean-Jean Lausse.
我不知道当时我在哪儿。我就是脑子一片空白。我看到了巴塞罗那那场灾难。在国际足球最高水平的赛场上看到那一幕真的很震撼。当时我就想，天哪。不过我是里昂队的超级粉丝。显然我在那儿踢过球，而且，你知道的，我和那里的主席让-让·欧拉斯（Jean-Michel Aulas）也算朋友，或者说至少挺熟的。
He's kind of a character and sort of just an interesting person in sports. I always appreciate that. So hopefully they do. And not only, so you played there, I mean, you only play there for you, but you know those people and you did play there and then you went back. And you won the World Cup in Lyon, right? I mean, how was that? It was really cool.
他算是个挺有性格的人，也是体育界一个挺有趣的人物。我一直很欣赏这一点。所以希望他们能赢。不仅是因为你在那儿踢过球——我的意思是，你虽然在那儿只踢了，但你确实认识那些人，而且你确实在那儿踢过球，后来你又回去了。你还在里昂赢得了世界杯，对吧？我的意思是，那感觉怎么样？真的很酷。
It was actually, we played the French team in the quarterfinals. That would have been something if we played them in finals. And I had this kind of sneaking suspicion that like, of course they wanted to win, but the French also like really loved our team too. I feel like we're everything the French want to be like, they want to be more outgoing. They want to be more whatever, but they're just still like a little bit caught in their insecurities or something. So once they were knocked out, I feel like everyone kind of piled on us and to do it
其实我们在四分之一决赛中踢了法国队。如果我们能在决赛中踢他们，那才叫真的有意思呢。而且我当时有一种隐约的感觉，就是当然他们肯定想赢，但法国人其实也非常喜欢我们的球队。我觉得我们就是法国人渴望成为的那种人——他们想要更外向，他们想要更随性，但他们还是有点被自己的不安全感所束缚之类的。所以一旦他们被淘汰出局，我觉得大家都开始支持我们了，而且能在
in a place that I had played in a beautiful stadium in France was pretty cool. Well, and then you were just such a standout and you did such amazing things. It was a great team and you stood out on a great team. The thing that I love the most is maybe my favorite, your very famous celebration, standing proud and standing tall, like doing that, that pose, which is so cool, so rad. And I'm, you know, I'm such a football fan. So it was great. Just watching, it was just unbelievable watching that.
一个我曾效力过的地方、在法国一座美丽的球场里做到这一点，真的是太酷了。而且，你当时真的是表现极其耀眼，做了那么多不可思议的事情。那是一支伟大的球队，而你在伟大的球队中脱颖而出。我最喜欢、也许是我最喜欢的，就是你那个非常著名的庆祝动作：骄傲而挺拔地站立，摆出那个姿势，太酷了，太帅了。而且，（你知道的）我是个铁杆足球迷。所以真的很棒。光是看着就觉得不可思议，看那个简直难以置信。
That was so exciting. And I always wonder like, because I can imagine the adrenaline and the rush and the buildup and working so hard and all the years and then you get to, and you've won it a couple times, but that was such a crowning achievement that 2019 World Cup, it was so tough and you guys played so well. It was such a great team. At the end of that, what is that come down like? Is that tough?
太激动人心了。我总是想知道——因为我可以想象那种肾上腺素飙升、兴奋感、赛前筹备、付出无数努力以及经历的所有年头，然后你终于达到了顶峰，虽然你已经赢过好几次了，但2019年的那届世界杯绝对是加冕之作，过程那么艰难，你们踢得那么好。那真是一支伟大的球队。在这一切结束之后，那种高潮过后的回落是什么感觉？很难受吗？
Is it gradual? Is it a month later? Like, you know, this one just felt so different because it, it just was about so much more than sports. So it's almost like, I don't know, I don't even feel like we had that kind of come down because even when the sports were over, like even just with the equal pay stuff and the way the team, you know, sort of acted during the tournament and the way we kind of held ourselves and all the stuff with the president and like all this, it just felt like it was
是逐渐平复的吗？还是一个月后才缓过来？你知道的，这次感觉太不一样了，因为它不仅仅关乎体育。所以几乎就像是，我不知道，我甚至不觉得我们经历了那种失落期，因为即使在比赛结束之后，甚至光是同工同酬的事情，以及球队在锦标赛期间的表现、我们保持自我态度的方式，还有跟主席之间的那些事，这一切都让人觉得
just a really happy, joyous moment, not only for us, but like for everyone. So I didn't really feel the come down in this one, which was kind of nice because you want that feeling to last for a while. Well, what was your come down like, Will, because yours is from 2010 and last year, right? The last, yeah, that was the last time that. Because that was a long come down. Um, Megan, excuse my ignorance.
这不仅对我们来说是一个非常快乐、喜庆的时刻，对每个人来说也是如此。所以我并没有真正感受到那种失落感，这其实挺不错的，因为你希望那种感觉能持续久一点。好吧，威尔，你的失落期是什么样的，因为你的战绩是2010年和去年的，对吧？最后一次，对，那是最后一次。因为那个回落期很长。嗯，梅根，原谅我的无知。
Period. We do it all the time, by the way, we have to do it all the time. Remind. We'll assess as we go. Remind me how things resolved, uh, with the whole, the president thing and the equal pay thing. And how did that, how did that whole plane land? The equal pay thing is still ongoing.
句号。我们经常这样，顺便说一句，我们总是得这样做。提醒一下。我们边走边评估。提醒我一下，关于主席事件和同工同酬的事情，最后到底是怎么解决的？整个事情最后是怎么平息落地的？同工同酬的事还在进行中。
Uh, we're basically like in the appellate process right now, which is, yeah, takes a long time in normal times and the best of times. And so obviously now everything is kind of slowed down, but that's still going. So wait. So that's an appeal. So, so then what was the initial ruling? So the initial room, basically the judge out of California, which we've disagreed with this, but he ruled on summary judgment for pretty much all of the financial part of the
我们目前基本上处于上诉阶段，这个过程，对，在正常时期和最佳状态下也需要很很长时间。所以显然现在一切都慢下来了，但这件事还在进行。等等。所以那是个上诉。那么，最初的裁决是什么？最初的裁决基本上是，加州的一个法官——虽然我们并不同意这一点——但他对诉讼中几乎所有的财务部分作出了简易判决，
lawsuit and said, essentially that we had chosen the type of contract that we wanted. And now we're upset that it didn't pay us as much, which in reality, if we could have had the same contract as the men, we would have taken it because it would have paid us three times more. Yeah. So essentially he said, we actually made more money, but I'm like, we won literally three times as much and played more important games and won two World Cups and all of that. So it was kind of the idea of like, we worked twice as hard and earned the same amount of
基本意思是说我们自己选择了想要的合同类型，现在又对拿到的薪水少感到不满。但实际上，如果我们能拿到和男球员一样的合同，我们绝对会接受，因为那样能多拿三倍的薪水。对。所以他基本上是说我们实际上赚得更多，而我的反应是：我们赢得了字面意义上三倍的奖金，踢了更重要的比赛，赢得了两次世界杯，还有所有这些。所以当时的想法就是：我们付出了两倍的努力，却赚了同样的钱。
money. And so he's like, oh yeah, you earned the same amount of money. We're like, I don't think that's how discrimination works. Sort of missed. Right. And so that's the general premise of discrimination. So he just ruled on those. There was a couple other like travel and the, you know, the type of hotels we stay and charter
然后他说：“哦，对啊，你们赚了同样的钱。”我们则觉得：我不觉得歧视是这么运作的。这有点偏离重点了。没错。所以这就是歧视的基本前提。他只是对这些做出了裁决。还有其他一些问题，比如差旅费、我们住的酒店类型、包机之类的，当时还没有最终定论。所以这些问题需要解决，
planes and stuff like that, that were still left open. So those need to be, we either need to go to trial or settle on those before we can formally appeal the other ones. So we're kind of working on those right now in the hopes that then pretty soon we can appeal, but then all of the court dates have been set back and, you know, because of COVID. So we can't really do anything right now. And again, forgive me for Jason's ignorance, but I'm going to ask a question. Sure, Jason, but you, the suit is against U.S. soccer, right?
我们要么通过审判解决，要么在正式上诉前达成和解。所以我们目前正在处理这些，希望很快能进入上诉阶段，但由于新冠疫情，所有的法庭开庭日期都被延期了。所以我们现在其实什么也做不了。再次为杰森的无知向你道歉，不过我要问个问题。当然可以，杰森，不过，你们起诉的对象是美国足协，对吧？
Yes. And they're trying to hold back. Now, what's crazy to me is women's soccer in this country draws far more viewers than men's soccer. And yet they're fighting for the right to pay you less. And also seems strange that like that's like saying, well, why don't we just piss off the people who are actually bringing us the revenue that is paying our salaries? Right.
是的。而他们一直在百般阻挠。现在，令我疯狂的是，这个国家的女子足球吸引的观众远多于男子足球。然而他们却在为“有权付给你们更少薪水”而战。而且这听起来也很奇怪，就好比说：“哦，为什么我们不直接惹怒那些实际上为我们带来带来薪水收入的人呢？”对。
Right. It just doesn't, it doesn't add up. I know. It's, it actually really is bizarre and just sort of shows that, you know, the kind of deep rooted and it, it things have changed a lot over the last, I don't know, probably eight years or so. We weren't always this popular, always making this much money, but, you know, the sort of unwillingness to shift or the lack of ability to shift and realize that you're actually
对。这根本说不通，完全说不通。我知道。这其实真的很诡异，也正说明了，你知道的，那种根深蒂固的思想——当然情况在过去，我不知道，大概八年左右的时间里已经发生了很大变化。我们以前并不总是这么受欢迎，不总是赚这么多钱，但是，那种不愿变通的僵化，或者说无法转变观念、意识到自己其实在
underselling this product that wins all the time, you know, particularly in this time as, you know, social justice starts to become more of a nationwide conversation and pay equity and women and all of that. I'm kind of like, you guys are just still digging in. Like this is really bad business, you know, even just from like a ruthless business perspective, I'm like, put your money in the social causes and like, you know, get behind women and get behind winners and all of that. So especially, I mean, we're winning World Cups, we're doing all the things.
低估这个屡战屡胜的团队的价值的无能，特别是在这个时期，你知道的，当社会公正开始更多地成为全社会的话题、薪酬平等、女性以及所有这些议题都被关注的时候。我当时就觉得：你们居然还在死守不放。这真的是很糟糕的商业决策，你知道的，哪怕仅仅从一个冷血的商业角度来看，我都觉得：把钱投入到社会事业中去，支持女性，支持赢家，等等。尤其是，我的意思是，我们在赢得世界杯，我们在做所有这些事情。
It's crazy. It's one of those things that you want to be like, Hey, if you were their friend, you'd want to be like, Hey, you know what? Even despite what you think, this is going to look really bad for you down the road. History will not reflect well on you. Like all the like, even if you, and it's crazy, you don't want to pay us. But even if you don't want to, you should just for self preservation reasons. That's what I keep saying.
这太疯狂了。这就是那种会让你忍不住想说：“嘿，如果你是他们的朋友，你会想说：‘嘿，你知道吗？不管你怎么想，这从长远来看对你的形象太糟糕了。历史不会对你们作出正面评价。’哪怕你，虽然这很疯狂，你们就是不想付给我们钱。但就算你真的不想付，为了自保你也应该付。”我一直这么说。
I know. I'm like, listen, I just deserve it because like this, you know, I'm good at what I do and the team is good and we draw ratings in this and that, but I'm like, even just over the course of these, you know, number of years, you know, the stance that they took on kneeling and all that, they've had to walk that back. The whole pay equity issue, it just seems like one PR nightmare after another. I mean, the last thing they sort of did was, I think it was in March, put in their legal brief that just inherently women are like lesser than men.
我知道。我当时就想：听着，我理应得到这些，因为这，你知道的，我擅长我的工作，团队也很优秀，我们能吸引收视率等等。但我甚至觉得，在过去的这些年里，你知道的，他们对下跪抗议等事件的立场，他们不得不收回那些言论。整个薪酬平等的问题，感觉就像一场接一场的公关噩梦。我的意思是，他们最近做的一件事，好像是在三月份，在法律简报中写道，女性天生就比男性低一等。
And I was like, Oh God, this can't be the argument that you're making. Like this is crazy. I was like, Oh my God, they said it out loud. This is insane. What are you doing? So this is US soccer. So there's a distinction between obviously a Olympic soccer, which is amateur and none of the athletes get paid.
当时我的反应是：天哪，这绝对不可能是你们拿出来的论点。这太疯狂了。我当时想：天哪，他们竟然把这种话大声说出来了。这太疯狂了。你们到底在干什么？所以这是美国足协。那么，显然奥运会足球和这个有区别，奥运会是业余性质的，所有的运动员都没有报酬。
But for World Cup, the athletes do get paid. Is that correct? So it's different on the men's side and the women's side. So for the men's side, it is an amateur tournament. I think you can have like two, you know, professional players or overage players. Like an under 23 tournament as to not take over the whole Olympics and make it like another World Cup. So that's what the men do.
但对于世界杯，运动员是有报酬的。是这样的吗？男女足在这方面是不同的。对于男足来说，这是一场业余赛事。我想你可以带两个，你知道的，职业球员或超龄球员。就像一个23岁以下的赛事，以免接管整届奥运会并把它变成另一届世界杯。所以男足是这么做的。
But for us, it is a fully professional tournament. So we have the World Cup and then the Olympics are supposed to be the year after, but we get paid fully for both. Gotcha. Yeah. So on the women's side, it's fully professional. On the men's side, it's still an amateur tournament. I got you.
但对我们来说，这是一场完全职业化的赛事。所以我们有世界杯，然后奥运会应该在第二年举行，但我们这两项赛事都有全额报酬。原来如此。对的。所以对女足来说，这是完全职业化的。对男足来说，它仍然是一项业余赛事。我明白了。
And that concludes our interview. Yeah, I don't, it seems like it's just real simple math. You know, the television stations that are airing your games, they should just simply look at the ad rates and those are predicated on ratings. And if you guys are getting higher ratings and therefore higher ad rates, you guys should have a commensurate share of that. It just doesn't, I don't understand why they would mess around with, uh, with solid indisputable numbers.
我们的采访到此结束。对，我不知道，这听起来就像是最简单的数学问题。转播你们比赛的电视台，他们只需简单看一下广告费率，而广告费率是基于收视率的。如果你们获得了更高的收视率，从而带来了更高的广告费率，你们就应该获得与之相称的分成。我只是不明白为什么他们要跟那些确凿无疑的硬数字过不去。
And when we say they, it's the U S soccer, what? Like federation. Federation. Okay. So it's like a profit, like governing body, basically. Do you have to deal with them on a daily, weekly, monthly basis? And is that weird now? And what is that like?
当我们说“他们”时，指的是美国足协，对吧？联。足协。好吧。所以它就像是一个营利性的管理机构，基本上是这样。你们需要每天、每周或每月与他们打交道吗？现在这样不是很尴尬吗？那是一种什么样的体验？
Yeah, it's gotten a little icy over the years. I mean, I can't imagine. It's always been kind of awkward because we've always been like low key, I'll just paint on us and like discriminating against us. And so we know that. And now as we've gotten more organized and, you know, our union is really strong now and we kind of have the structures around us to really fight it appropriately. Um, it's just difficult cause they are still the bosses and it's like, that's the only
对，这些年关系变得有点冷淡。我的意思是，我简直无法想象。这种关系一直有点尴尬，因为他们一直以来都在暗中，你知道的，打压我们，对我们进行歧视。所以我们心里清楚。现在，随着我们越来越团结，你知道的，我们的工会现在非常强大，并且我们周围有了能够进行恰当抗争的组织结构，
national team we can play for. But in turn, we're the only players that are going to play for you. So it's awkward all around. But it seems completely fruitless on their side since you guys hold a hundred percent of the leverage. All you guys have to do is say, guess what? We're not playing effectively striking. And then they can try to say, Oh, we'll just get different players.
这就变得很困难，因为他们依然是老板，而且你知道的，那是我们唯一能代表效力的国家队。但反过来说，我们也是唯一能为他们效力的球员。所以整体感觉处处都很尴尬。但在他们看来，这完全是徒劳的，因为你们掌握了百分之百的主动权。你们所有人需要做的就是说：“猜怎么着？我们不踢了。”实际上就是罢工。然后他们可以试图说：“哦，我们去找别的球员好了。”
And then they'll go out there and they'll realize, Oh, the best players are the ones that are saying that they don't want to play. So they would never field a team of people who didn't know how to play. So why don't you just say, guess what? Here's the price. And if you don't pay it, you can, uh, have these, uh, people that don't know how to play very well. But then they have to keep saying, guess what?
然后他们派人上场，就会发现：“哦，最优秀的球员正是那些说不想踢的人。”所以他们永远组建不了一支由不懂踢球的人组成的队伍。那你们为什么不直接说：“猜怎么着？这就是身价。如果你们不付，你们就只能让这些不太会踢球的人上场了。”但随后他们就得一直说：“猜怎么着？”
And I don't, and then they're going to be like, what? But I think here's the thing. What you guys should, and that's a game nobody ever wins. Guess what? Hey, guess what? Hey, guess what? But, but you know what you should do is find a country. Find some rogue nation and say, and say, Hey, you guys want to win the World Cup every
我不觉得，然后他们就会问：“什么？”但我认为关键在于：你们应该，而且那是一场没有人能赢的游戏。“猜怎么着？嘿，猜怎么着？嘿，猜怎么着？”但是，你知道你们应该怎么做吗？去找一个国家。找一个流氓国家，然后说：“嘿，你们想每次都赢得世界杯吗？”
time? Yeah. Cause we've got 11 players or, you know, what a deep squad of 20, right? Yeah. And here we go. And we're, and just take it to the highest bidder and have some country that will be, you know, like, I don't know, like, uh, and Dora, you know, up in the Pyrenees and they're like, yeah, we'll have a winning World Cup team.
“对啊，因为我们有11名球员，或者说，多棒的一个20人的豪华阵容啊，对吧？”“对啊，我们这就上。”然后把它出价给最高竞标者，找一个愿意接受的国家，你知道的，比如安道尔（Andorra），位于比利牛斯山脉，他们会说：“行啊，我们愿意拥有一支能赢得世界杯的球队。”“我们就选这个。没问题。”对啊，我的意思是，我们的合同快到期了。我想我们的合同明年到期。所以那绝对是一个我们不再接受降薪的契机。
Let's take that. No problem. Yeah. I mean, our, our contract is coming up. I think our contract is up next year. So that is definitely a time where we're sort of done, um, taking the pay cuts. And that would be before the next World Cup, right? That's once every four years.
那会在下一届世界杯之前，对吧？四年一次的那种。那会在之前。对。太好了。我等不及了。我真的很希望你们能狠狠地给他们点颜色看看。狠狠收拾他们。
That would be before. Yeah. Good. I can't wait. I really hope you guys turn the screws on them. Stick it to them. Yeah. Can I ask a dumb, dumb question when I watch soccer?
我能问一个很蠢很蠢的问题吗，当我观看足球比赛时？因为我上次踢球，我想我大概只有五六岁，而且，我总是看你们踢球，我感到非常着迷。你们从来、从来没有一刻停止过奔跑，一刻也没有。你觉得你们在一场比赛里跑了多少英里的该死的路程？因为你们不像篮球那样，篮球也是一刻不停地移动。但像橄榄球、棒球、高尔夫，都属于休闲类的运动，而这个项目，你们是真的一刻都不停地跑啊。别提什么高尔夫了。
Because I, last time I played, I think I was like five or six years old and, um, I always watch you guys play and I'm fascinated. It's you never, ever stop running ever. How many f-ing miles do you think you run in a game? Because you only have the game like basketball, you never stop moving either. But like football, baseball, golf, all kind of like leisure, but this is like, you don't stop running ever. Don't even mention golf.
你在干什么？有很多走路。对吧。你知道我的意思吗？我在那儿走来走去。那跑得可真多。大概有，根据你踢的位置，一场比赛大概要跑6到8英里。
What are you doing? A lot of walking. Yeah. You know what I mean? I'm walking there. It's a lot. It's like, it's like six to eight, depending on your position, it's like six to eight miles a game.
但这就是那种持续不断的跑动。球场太大了。你们一直在跑，为了做到这一点，要跑很远的距离。如果我们游说把比赛时间缩短一点怎么样？我不会讨厌这个主意的。我完全不反对。
But it is just the constant. The field is so big. Your constant, you're running really far to do it. What about if we lobbied to make it shorter? I wouldn't hate it. I wouldn't hate it. So can I ask you one question? So just to get back and kind of put a final, put it to bed about the whole equal pay thing.
那我能问你一个问题吗？回到刚才的话题，给同工同酬的事情做一个最终的了结。倒不是说我想把它了结。我希望这件事一直保持热度，我希望你们能获胜并把这些家伙彻底击溃。但与此同时，我在看那部关于尼古拉·阿内尔卡（Nicolas Anelka）的纪录片，他是一个非常著名的足球运动员。
And not that I want to put it to bed. I want it to be out there and I want you to be win and crush these guys. But at the same time, I watched that documentary about that guy, Nico Inelka, who's a very famous soccer player. Yeah. Really great. It's cool, right? Yeah.
对。真的非常棒。很酷，对吧？对。真的很好。法国人。很有趣。超级有意思。一个来自巴黎的家伙。他为很多不同的球队效力过。部分原因在于——如果我错了请纠正我——据我看来，他是一个对自己很有价值认同感的人，他总是觉得：“我很棒，我应该去最好的地方踢球。”
Really good. French guy. Interesting. Super interesting. Guy from Paris. And he played for a bunch of different teams. And part of the reason was, it seems to me, and correct me if I'm wrong, was that he was a guy who always, he valued himself and he was like, I'm really great and I should play
结果他一度选择离开，他有点无视那些关于球员转会的成文或不成文的规则，决定离开巴黎圣日耳曼（PSG）去阿森纳。而法国足协——曾培养过他、让他从法国国家青训体系中一步步走出来的那群人——对此愤怒至极，因为他竟然敢这么做，而且他赢了，因为他有理有据。他的态度是：“看吧，这是我提供劳务的地方，我应该掌控我自己的劳务，而且法律规定我这么做是合法的。”
the best place. And he ended up at one point, he left, he sort of defied the rules and that, that were kind of some written and some unwritten about player transfers and he decided to leave PSG to go to Arsenal and the French Football Federation, who had groomed him, he'd come up through the French national program, were so pissed off that he did that and that, and he won because he had a case. He was like, look, these are where my services, I should be in charge of my services and the law states that I can do this.
他们当时气疯了，以至于到了挑选1998年法国世界杯法国队阵容的时候，他们居然没有选他。而他当时是一名不可思议的前锋。他本该进入那支球队的。当然最后他们还是赢了，但他本该进入那支球队的。在他身上，我看到很多类似悲剧的影子。他是一个直言不讳的人，超级聪明，在很多方面都是一个开拓者，而且他很有个性。我觉得，（我不是想让你难堪，）但我觉得你身上也有很多这样的特质，你懂得——你刚才也说过——你是一个伟大的球员。
They were so mad that when it came time to pick the World Cup team of 1998 that played in France, they didn't pick him for the team and he was an incredible striker. He should have been on that squad. Now they won anyway, but he should have been on that squad and he fell victim, it seemed to me a lot too. He was an outspoken guy, super smart guy and he was a trailblazer in a lot of ways and he was an individual. And I think that, you know, not to embarrass you, but I think that you share a lot of those
这绝对是轻描淡写了。你是一名如此不可思议的运动员。你是一名如此伟大的足球运动员，你是一个如此出色的榜样，并且你愿意为了理想挺身而出、孤注一掷。当对象是美国总统或是为了同工同酬而与美国足协斗争时，这肯定很吓人，这会让你成为一个众矢之的，对吧？这种情况有时，你会不会觉得自己承担了太多的压力？
same traits that you understand, you said it before, you're a great player. That's such an understatement. You're such an incredible athlete. You're such a great footballer and you're such a great role model and you are willing to put yourself out there on the line. And that's got to be scary when it's the president of the United States or fighting US soccer for the equal pay, it puts a target on you a little bit, right? And does that ever, and sometimes does it feel like you're taking a lot of the weight,
你知道这样做是正确的，因为你在为后来者开辟道路。在某些特定时刻，你会意识到这一点吗？因为我觉得这需要巨大的勇气，我对你的所作所为真的佩服得五体投地。对，太棒了。谢谢你。我，你知道的，其实并没有。
you know that it's the right thing to do because you're opening the door? Does that occur to you at certain points? Cause I think it takes a lot of courage and I am truly in awe of what you do. Yeah, great. Well, thank you. I, you know, it doesn't. No, sorry. That was for Megan.
不，抱歉。那是对梅根说的。那是对梅根说的，肖恩。哦，不好意思。那你继续。哦，我当时想：请跟我们讲讲你不得不背负的那个不可思议的沉重背包吧。老实说，我觉得两者兼而有之。我认为有些人的性格和特质就是更适合应对这些。而且，我确实觉得自己有那么一点这种特质，尼古拉（阿内尔卡）也有点这方面的特质。
That was for Megan, Sean. That was, oh, I'm sorry. So go ahead. Oh, I was like, do tell us the incredible backpack you have to carry. I think it's a little bit of both, to be honest. I think that there are certain personalities and people who are just better suited. And I, I do think that I have a little bit of that, you know, Nico had a little bit of that.
你们非常不同。你们是不同的人。我不是说你们是一样的，但是——对。但我确实认为，某些性格能够更好地处理这种状况，或者出于某种原因，在其中感到更自在。我想，在充满强大女性的团队中长大并逐渐成熟，通常情况下，如果你是一名女性，而且你在你所从事的领域里出类拔萃——我经常这么说——
You guys are very different. You're different people. I'm not saying you're the same, but yeah. But I do think that there's certain personalities that handle it a little bit better or just more comfortable in it for whatever reason. I think to being, you know, sort of growing up and maturing on a team full of very powerful women where normally if you're a woman and you're elite in whatever you do, I say this a lot.
就像你是凤毛麟角的存在。要么你是办公室里的首席执行官，要么你就是万里挑一、寥寥无几的那一个。所以我觉得，作为一个在世界上成长起来的女性，作为一个女性运动员，我和球队里的所有人一样，经历了一种独特的体验：我们在自己的回音室里长大，在那里我们不必以“凤毛麟角的精英女性”身份去独自面对世界。我们生活的世界里有23到25个像我们这样的女孩。所以我们几乎能从彼此身上获得那种自信。因此，我们几乎是在这种奇异的正能量和相互鼓励的回音室中长大的。
Like you're one of the only ones you're either, you know, the, you know, CEO in the office or, you know, you're sort of one of one or one of very few. And so I think as a, as a woman growing up in the world and as a female athlete, I sort of had this unique experience as we all did on the team of growing up in our own echo chamber where we don't have to live in the world as an elite woman who's one of one. We live in a world where there's 23 or 25 of us. And so we kind of get that confidence from each other almost. And so we grow up almost in this bizarre echo chamber of positivity and like encouragement
而且我不知道。我的意思是，我觉得我们从小到大，在这支球队里，从很小的时候起，身边就一直围绕着大量的媒体，我们无时无刻不在聚光灯下。无论我们是在踢一场友谊赛还是在踢世界杯，我们总是被寄予必须取胜的期望。当你加入美国国家女子足球队时，这就是你必须接受的现实。所以我们拥有独特的适应能力。
for each other. And then I don't know. I mean, I think we grew up to like, we've had so much media around us all the time, you know, since a very young age on this team, we're constantly in the media. We constantly have pressure because no matter if we're playing a friendly or in the World Cup, we're always expected to win. And that's just kind of the deal when you play on the women's national team. And so we're sort of uniquely suited.
一旦到了这些重大时刻，我觉得这其实是我们相比许多其他球队所拥有的优势——我们在国内经常面对媒体。我们做了大量的赞助合作。我们做了大量的品牌交易。我们做了大量的公开亮相。我们一直处于公众视野中。所以当我们遇到这些更大的场面时，我们能更好地适应。而在那种“向权势说真话”的事情上，我觉得，你知道的，既然我们已经取得了如此巨大的成功，
Once we get to these big moments, I think that's the strength we have actually over a lot of other teams is that we do a lot of media at home. We do a lot of sponsorship deals. We do a lot of brand deals. We do a lot of appearances. We're kind of constantly out there. And so when we get to these bigger moments, we're a little bit more suited for it. And in terms of like the speaking truth to power thing, I just feel like, you know, being
我们就会得到那种积极的反馈：是的，我们是精英；是的，品牌方愿意与我们合作。这甚至有点像——品牌方付给我们的出场费和交流费，比我们自己的足协付给我们的、去赢得该死的世界杯的奖金还要高。这简直太疯狂了。所以我想，当这两件奇怪的现实交织在一起时，然后我们站在足协面前或是其他什么场合，我们就会觉得：不，这不对劲。
as successful as we've been. So we have that kind of like positive feedback of like, yes, we're elite, yes, brands want to work with us. It's almost like brands are paying us more to just show up and like talk to people than our own Federation is paying us to actually go win the damn World Cup. Like it's kind of crazy. So I think that like weird reality of those two things, then we get in, you know, in front of the Federation or whatever it is, and we're like, no, this is not, this is not right.
这根本不应该是现在这个样子。然后“总统事件”就更离谱了，那简直是史上最诡异的。对。那件事最后是怎么解决的？最终结果是什么？嗯，他大概在别的地方被另一个闪闪发光的东西吸引注意力了吧。对。
This is not kind of what should be happening. And then the President thing was just so, that was just the weirdest. Yeah. How did that resolve? Like, what was the final? Well, he got distracted looking at another shiny object probably somewhere else. Yeah. Exactly.
我的意思是，基本上他说了他该说的话，大意就是：闭嘴，赢了球再说话。而我们的反应是：扶好你们的啤酒。我们做到了。然后事情就变成了：“哦，对不起，我没听见你接下来还说了什么。”在我们夺冠之后，实际上白宫和政府甚至试图通过后门进行接触，说：“嘿，我们可以搞点什么两党合作之类的吗？”因为佩洛西（Nancy Pelosi）之前说过一些话，比如欢迎你们来国会山。舒默（Chuck Schumer）好像也说过。所以他们当时想的是：也许我们可以搞点跨党派的活动。而我们的回答是：我们特么才不去呢。
I mean, basically he said what he said, like, you know, basically just shut up and win before you talk. And we were like, hold our beer. Did that. And then it was kind of like, oh, sorry, I didn't hear anything else from you. After that, after we won, I think actually the White House of the Administration tried to reach out sort of backdoor of like, hey, can we do some kind of like bipartisan, like, you know, whatever, because Pelosi had said stuff, like you guys are more than welcome
我们已经告诉过你们了，而且我们不想再重复一遍，我们就是不去。但是，你知道的，威尔刚才提到，你有勇气成为一个显而易见正义之举的代言人，冒着成为靶子、不得不应对随之而来的任何后果的风险，这绝对是，这并非独一无二，但确实极其罕见。然而现在这个时代太需要这个了，比以往任何时候都更需要——当然一直都需要，但现在比以往更甚，我敢说，而且对于所有看着你长大的年轻女孩们来说，看到这一切，
to come to the Hill. I think Schumer as well. So they were like, maybe we can do some kind of bipartisan thing and we're like, we're not fucking going. We told you and we didn't tell you again, we're not going. It's just, but, you know, what Will was talking about, you know, your courage to be the figurehead of something that you're clearly right on at the risk of being a target and having to deal with whatever consequences may come is just, you know, it's not unique, but it
你知道的，我们不是在无理取闹，我们在向权力说出真相，我们是正义的，当你具备判断对错的能力时，就不应该对站出来说真话感到恐惧——就像你不是在信口开河，你知道自己有道理，这是经过深思熟虑的，并且去承担随之而来的后果，无论后果是什么，这都无所谓，只要你知道，我们是在为正确的事情挺身而出。我们今天太需要这种精神了。
is rare, but it is, it's so needed nowadays, more so, I mean, it's always been needed, but more so now than ever, I would imagine, and for all the young girls that are watching you as well, to see that, you know, we're not a pain in the ass, we are speaking truth to power, we are right, and there should be no fear about coming forward and saying that you are right when you have the ability to judge whether you are right or you are wrong, like you're not just popping off, you know, you have a good point, it's vetted and deal with the consequences, whatever they are, it doesn't matter as long as, you know, we're standing up for what is, what is correct, we need that so much today.
我觉得我确实理解这一点，而且特别是过去三四年里，感觉好像每次我们发声，或者我发声说点什么，总是那群特定的人在生气。你知道的，甚至当我单膝下跪的时候，大家的反应是：“好吧，所有这些特定类型的人都在生气，那我肯定做对了什么。”生气的人里面没有一个长得跟我一样的，没有一个是黑人，没有一个是处于边缘化或其他什么地位的人。所以我觉得我确实理解并高度重视这样一个事实：我的声音确实产生了影响，而且产生了超乎寻常的影响。
And I think I do understand that and sort of, I think, especially in the last three or four years, it seems like, you know, every time we speak up or I speak up and say something, it's kind of the same people being mad, you know, like even when I knelt, it was like, okay, all of these particular kind of people are mad, I must be doing something right, it's like, it's nobody who looks like me, it's nobody who's, you know, like black, it's nobody who, you know, is in sort of a position, maybe they're marginalized or whatever, so I think I do understand and take very seriously the fact that my voice does have impact and it has outsized impact.
我的意思是，我只是一个人，但不管出于什么原因，我拥有这个平台，生活在一个崇拜体育和名人的国家里，所以这种影响力无论如何都会被放大。基本上我所需要做的就是——虽然我也受过教育，知道自己在说些什么——把这些话说出来，因为我觉得当我表达这些观点时，我是在为许多没有发声渠道的人发声。所以这就像是，伴随着我所能产生的影响力，这就是我肩负的责任，而其他人通过他们所能产生的影响力，也会承担起不同的责任。
I mean, I'm just one person, but for whatever reason, have this platform and live in a country that glorifies sports and glorifies celebrities so that the impact is going to be outsized anyways. And so basically all I have to do is, you know, I may be educated and know what I'm talking about, but just say the things, because there's a lot of other, I feel like when I'm saying these things, I'm saying it for a lot of people that don't have those voices. So it's like, that's kind of my responsibility with the impact that I can have, and other people will have a different responsibility with the impact that they can have as well.
你毕业时拿的是什么学位？因为你是个超级大聪明。哦天哪，可不是什么超级大聪明。我修的，我记得是社会学，辅修了政治学，但主要是社会学，因为这门课比较轻松而且很综合。对，一样，一样，对。但确实如此，你说话带有一种，有一种极其清晰的逻辑，你谈论事情的方式是那么冷静、那么直接，这真的很有道理，让人很容易产生共鸣，而且我认为这超级重要。说实话，再次声明，我知道我像个追星族一样表现得狂热崇拜，但我真的觉得你
What was your degree in when you graduated, because you're a super smarty? Oh dear, nothing super smarty, I did, I think it was sociology and a minor in political science, but mostly like sociology, because it was pretty easy and complex. Yeah, same, same, yeah. But it's true, like you speak with such a sort of, there's such a clarity and sort of you're so sober in the way that you talk about stuff and so direct, and it really makes sense and it's really easy to identify with, and I think it's super important. I think honestly, again, I know I'm so gushingly like Starstruck, but I just think you're
在各个方面都是一个如此不可思议的榜样。那么，哪个城市最适合派对？完美的过渡。不，我想问你一个关于苏·伯德（Sue Bird）的问题。最棒的，对吧？对，她是最棒的。最棒的。所以苏·伯德不仅是你的伴侣，也是一位现象级的运动员。
such an incredible role model across the board. And so what city's best to party in? Beautiful segue. No, I want to ask you a question about Sue Bird. The best, right? Yeah, she's the best. The best. So Sue Bird is also, is your partner, but also a phenomenal athlete.
在一个家里，那种氛围是怎样的？你们俩会为每件事都争强好胜吗？其实我们并没有一直在竞争，但对我来说，每一天都是一堂生动的“保持谦逊”的课，因为她的成就比我高太多了。比如，我们刚开始约定时，我妈妈做了一次，你知道的，她那必不可少的快速谷歌搜索，然后她说：“嗯，你以前可比现在impressive（令人印象深刻）多了。”对。我说：“好吧，确实，你说得对。”我就觉得：太酷了。
And what is that like in a household, do you guys constantly compete over everything? We don't actually constantly compete, but it is just, it's just humble pie all day long for me because she's so much more accomplished than I am. I'm like, my mom actually said when we first started dating, she did, you know, her obligatory quick Google search and she was like, well, you used to be a lot more impressive. Yeah. I was like, well, yeah, you're right. I'm like, oh, it's so cool.
你知道的，我已经赢得了一枚奥运金牌，而苏的反应是：“我有四枚。”然后你妈就会说，而你的反应是：“我们要过去吃晚饭了。”然后你妈会问：“苏也来吗？”对。这就好像，这从来不是一个人的事情。对。实际上，我们——虽然作为运动员，我们俩都很争强好胜，但我们非常
We know I've won an Olympic gold medal and Sue's like, I have four. Yeah. And then your mom's like, you're like, we're coming over for dinner and mom's like, well, is Sue coming? Yeah. It's like, just, this isn't a one person thing. Right. We're actually, I mean, we're both competitive, obviously, being athletes, but we very much
看重把那种胜负欲留在体育赛场上，转而去做其他事情，从中抽离出来。我们俩都不是那种“食、息、寝无时无刻不在想着体育”的人。对。那是我的下一个问题。你知道，我总是说，医生不会跑回家去看电视剧《急诊室的故事》（ER）的重播。不会的。所以我也无法想象你们会那样。
value leaving that where it is in the sports and just doing other things and getting out of it. Neither of us are like, eat, breath, sleep, like the sport all the time. Yeah. That was my next question. You know, I always say like, doctors don't run home and watch reruns of ER. No. So I can't imagine you guys.
我从来没听你这么说过。我 literalmente（字面意义上）从来没听过，而且我认识你20年了。我们是20年的好朋友了。好吧。我脑子里确实经常闪过这种想法。但事实确实如此。你大概不会一溜烟跑回家，只为了在电视上看无休止的体育节目吧。所以你一直在踢我们叫“soccer”、杰森和肖恩叫“soccer”的足球，
I've never heard you say that. I've literally never, and I've known you for 20 years. We've been good friends for 20 years. Okay. I have a lot of those kind of thoughts running through my head. But it's true. Like you probably don't run home to go just watch endless sports things on TV. So you've been playing football as we call it soccer and Jason and Sean call it soccer,
但我们叫它“football”。对。对。懂行的人都是这么叫的。对。所以你从很小的时候起就一直保持着极高的水准。你知道的，我有一个好朋友，我们不久前在播客里请过他，他职业冰球打了22年。
but we call it football. Yeah. Yeah. As the people who know. Yeah. So we've been doing it since a very young age at a very high level. And you know, I have a good friend of mine who we had on the podcast a while ago who played hockey for 22 years professionally.
但是我们叫它足球。对。是的。对于懂的人来说。是的。所以我们从小就在很高的水平上踢球。你知道的，我有一个好朋友，前不久他来过我们的播客，他职业冰球生涯长达22年。
And I knew watching him kind of retire and what that was like that all of a sudden. So you've been doing this thing at this highest level and you're still doing it. And like you said, like, you know what your year is, you know what your tournaments you're going to play, you know what your season is. And, and that's a very. It's a very strange existence. Right. Yeah.
我知道看着他退役的那种感觉，那种生活一下子就变了。你一直站在最高水平做这件事，而且你还在继续。就像你说的，你知道你的一年是怎么过的，你知道你要参加哪些比赛，你知道你的赛季是什么样子的。这是一种非常非常奇怪的存在。对吧？是的。
And then you, because it's, but it's all you know so far. Well to that point, I always think that too, like, you know, you can only watch so many documentaries about sports figures who all the talk about what they're going to do after they can't play anymore. And is that on your mind and what does that look like? Hopefully it's not for years and years because you're young and incredible shape. Thank you. But you know, do you think about that and what does that look like for you?
然后你，因为这是，但这目前是你唯一知道的。说到这儿，我总是会这么想，你看，你只能看那么多关于体育明星的纪录片，他们都在谈论当他们不能再比赛后要做什么。你会考虑这个问题吗？那会是什么样子？希望这不会在很多年之后发生，因为你还年轻，状态好得不得了。谢谢。但是，你会考虑这个问题吗？对你来说那会是什么样子？
Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. I definitely think about it, especially, you know, closer to the, to the end of it than the beginning of it. And I'm trying to, you know, prepare as much as I can and sort of do other things. I mean, the pandemic, frankly, has been, you know, that's been the silver lining for me is, is to do a lot more of other things and what do I like and what, what do I not like
谢谢。对，是的。我绝对会考虑，特别是，你知道，离结束的时候比开始的时候更近了。我在试着，你知道，尽可能地做好准备，并尝试做一些其他的事情。我的意思是，坦白说，这场大流行，你知道，对我来说这是不幸中的万幸，就是去做更多其他的事情，我喜欢什么，我不喜欢什么
and how much media do I like and do I want to be in sports or other things? Will you go into politics, please? Yeah. I know. I was thinking the same thing. People keep saying that. Please. I don't know.
我有多喜欢媒体工作，我是想从事体育行业还是其他事情？你要去从政吗？拜托。对。我知道。我也在这么想。人们一直这么说。拜托。我不知道。
It seems like. Well, but you studied political science. Please be a senator from California for us and then become president. Where do you live? California? We're in Seattle right now and we spend a lot of time like out in Connecticut area, New York area. That's where Sue's from.
感觉好像。嗯，但你学的是政治学。请给我们当个来自加州的参议员，然后当总统。你住在哪？加州？我们现在在西雅图，我们花了很多时间在康涅狄格地区、纽约地区。那是苏的家乡。
But you're from California. But I'm from California. Yeah. So I think about, I mean, I think it'll, it'll have to be, I'm sure it'll be hard. I'm sure I'll need therapy for it and like, you know, existential crisis, like for sure. Yeah, I have the number for you. Yeah. Thank you.
但你来自加州。但我来自加州。是的。所以我想，我的意思是，我觉得这一定，我确信这会很难。我确信我需要为此去看心理医生，比如，你知道，存在主义危机，肯定的。是的，我有你的电话号码。是的。谢谢。
I'm going to need that. You know, I get asked the politics question a lot and I do think the mold for politicians is totally breaking apart, which I think is amazing. We need more younger people, first of all, and we just need more people from different kind of walks of life and it can't just be this sort of entrenched club that, that never kind of breaks up. It seems like a lot though. I don't know, I can't imagine being like vetted and fact checked for my whole life, never
我到时候会需要的。你知道，我经常被问到政治方面的问题，而且我确实认为政客的模式正在彻底瓦解，我认为这太棒了。首先，我们需要更多年轻人，而且我们需要更多来自不同生活背景的人，它不能只是这种从来不会解散的根深蒂固的小圈子。感觉有很多事情，我不知道，我无法想象自己的一生都要受到背景审查和事实核查，从来
thinking I was going to be a politician and then trying to be a politician. They'd be like, all these receipts are not okay. Well, right. But we'll see. I think that whole sort of puritanical, you know, resume I think is, is less necessary in today's day and age as far as like, well, I can't run to be a politician because, because I, I smoked grass in 10th grade. Like, I think Trump kind of blew that out of the water.
没想过自己要当政客，然后又试图去当政客。他们会觉得，所有这些黑历史都不行。好吧，对吧。但我们走着瞧。我认为那种带有清教徒色彩的，你知道的简历，在当今时代已经没那么必要了，至于像，嗯，我不能竞选政客，因为，因为我在10年级时抽过大麻。我觉得特朗普有点打破了这个常规。
So as long as you're clear-headed and common sense and fair, I think you've got a really good shot. There's a flushing, I think, that's, that's happening. God willing. God willing. Smoked grass. Smoked. God willing.
所以只要你头脑清醒、通情达理、公正，我觉得你真的很有胜算。我觉得，正在发生某种洗牌。但愿如此。但愿如此。抽大麻。抽过。但愿如此。
That's what the kids are doing. I hear. Jason. The grass. Jason, what the fuck, man? They're smoking the weed. Jason, the guy whose iPhone light is always on by mistake, you know, and you're like, hey grandpa, Jesus.
我听说现在孩子们都在这么干。杰森。大麻。杰森，搞什么鬼，老兄？他们在抽大麻。杰森，那个iPhone闪光灯总是不小心一直开着的人，你知道的，然后你会说，嘿，爷爷，天哪。
Why is my battery 2%? What the, what's a tick-tock? But wait, you, you, you're talking about a couple things that you're learning that you like to do. What, what is one of them? Um. Like, do you want to follow in the footsteps of a Kaepernick who started it, you know, got a deal and maybe in media and anything like that or?
为什么我的电池只有2%？什么，什么是TikTok？但是等等，你，你，你刚才提到了一些你正在学习并且喜欢做的事情。什么，其中一个是什麽？嗯。比如，你想效仿卡佩尼克那样，他开始做这个，你知道的，拿到了合同，也许涉足媒体或者类似的事情吗？
I do have a lot of interest in sports media and, and the storytelling around sports media. I think that such a better job could be done, especially with female athletes. You know, whereas with male athletes, you get a thousand stories every day about everything. And that, that's what drives the excitement and the fandom of the game. It's not like people, you know, show up to a Lakers game and everyone's a die-hard basketball fan knowing all the plays. No, people just like to be entertained, right? And so if you know, you know, the story of, you know, whatever player, not even LeBron
我对体育媒体确实有很多兴趣，而且对围绕体育媒体的故事讲述也很感兴趣。我觉得其实可以做得更好，尤其是针对女性运动员。你知道，相比之下，对于男运动员，你每天都能看到关于每件事的成千上万个故事。而这正是推动比赛兴奋感和粉丝热情的动力。这并不是说人们，你知道的，去看湖人队的比赛，然后每个人都是死忠篮球球迷，对所有战术了如指掌。不，人们只是想找点乐子，对吧？所以如果你了解，你知道的，某个球员的故事，甚至都不是勒布朗·
James, cause he's the best, but you know, like a Gevel McGee or, you know, whatever, any of these other players, like you just know so much more about them. You get hooked in the storyline and then all of a sudden you're in. Right. The Olympics did a great job of that. Right. That Rune Arledge thing going way back. The Olympics does a great job.
詹姆斯，因为他是最棒的，但你知道，比如贾维尔·麦基，或者别的什么人，任何这些其他的球员，你只是对他们了解得更多。你被故事情节吸引进去，然后突然之间你就入迷了。对吧？奥运会在这方面做得很好。对吧。鲁恩·阿尔利奇的那套做法可以追溯到很久以前。奥运会在这方面做得很棒。
But they always do. Like, you know, I got into football on a Liverpool supporter because my writing partner, Chappy, we started watching champions like, and he would say, this is like sort of eight years ago and he started saying, Oh, this guy's great cause he came over. He used to play with this other manager and he started telling me the stories of these guys who were playing. And once I got into that, once that clicked and I was like, Oh, Jürgen Klopp used to be the manager at Borussia Dortmund.
但他们总是这样。就像，你知道的，我开始看足球并成为利物浦球迷，因为我的编剧搭档查比，我们开始看欧冠，然后他会说，这大概是八年前的事了，他开始说，哦，这家伙真棒，因为他是转会过来的。他以前和另一个教练共事，他开始告诉我这些踢球的家伙的故事。一旦我迷上了那个，一旦那种感觉对了，我就想，哦，于尔根·克洛普以前是多特蒙德的主教练。
He won there. And then he came to think and I'm like, you're in. Yeah. The stories are a lot more, like for me, I know you wouldn't know it by looking at me or knowing me that I'm not that huge of a sports follower. Who's Michael Jordan? Who's Michael Jordan? Quick.
他在那里赢得了冠军。然后他来到这里，我想，你陷进去了。是的。这些故事要多得多，对我来说，我知道你看我的外表或了解我，可能不会觉得我对体育有那么狂热。谁是迈克尔·乔丹？谁是迈克尔·乔丹？快说。
He's my basketball player. He's a last dancer. He's a last dancer. And so, but like, to what will that hilarious, it's got the answer in the title, I must watch it. I love it. So, no, so, Scotty, Scotty, Scotty. So no, but to Will's point, I find those stories fascinating, like all those documentaries
他是我的篮球运动员。他是“最后之舞”。他是“最后之舞”。所以，但是，多搞笑啊，答案就在标题里，我必须看它。我太喜欢了。所以，不，所以，斯科蒂，斯科蒂，斯科蒂。所以不，但说到威爾的观点，我发现这些故事非常迷人，就像所有这些关于运动员故事的纪录片一样，
like about the athlete's stories, sure, the games are interesting to watch and fun to watch. There are new deep dives in the statistics of sports or whatever. But I agree with you. Like the people's stories are what fascinate most people. The story behind the story. Megan, are you too young to remember indoor soccer? Kind of.
当然，比赛本身看起来很有趣也很过瘾。关于体育统计数据或者其他什么的新深度剖析也有。但我同意你的看法。就像人们的故事才是最吸引大多数人的东西。故事背后的故事。梅根，你太年轻了，不记得室内足球了吗？差不多吧。
Yeah. I mean, I know it a little bit, but yeah, like is it the MISL? Megan and I are both too young to know that. I don't know what happened to that, but it is awesome. I mean, you basically play it inside a hockey ring and you put like Astro Turf down on the ice. It's like hockey soccer. Just bananas.
是的。我的意思是，我知道一点，但是，是的，是MISL吗？我和梅根都太年轻了，不知道那个。我不知道后来怎么了，但它太棒了。我的意思是，你基本上是在一个冰球场里面踢，然后在冰面上铺上人造草皮。这就像冰球加足球。简直太疯狂了。
I loved it. You really did. I remember that. Arena football. Is that still around? No. Arena football is gone. So I'm going to ask you this question.
我太喜欢了。你真的很喜欢。我记得那个。室内美式足球。那个还在吗？没有了。室内美式足球已经没了。所以我要问你这个问题。
This is usually what Sean asked, but I'm going to ask it because he hasn't, which is, what are you, what are you? We're not letting him get in there. I'm not going to let him. I just want to hang out with you and Sue and me and Scotty. Well, me too. So what do you guys do when you hang out? What's your favorite thing to do?
通常这是肖恩问的，但我要问，因为他还没问，那就是，你们是，你们是？我们不让他插话。我不会让他得逞的。我只想和你、苏、我还有斯科蒂一起待会儿。好吧，我也是。那你们在一起的时候都做些什么？你们最喜欢做的事是什么？
But everybody wants to know, what do you guys do? What do they actually do? What do you actually do? Pets? Anything? No. No pets. I mean, I can't even keep a plant alive.
但每个人都想知道，你们到底在干嘛？他们实际上在干嘛？你们实际在干嘛？宠物？有什么吗？没有。没有宠物。我的意思是，我连一盆植物都养不活。
It would just, it's just like, travel so much and then like, a lot of my friends and teammates have pets and I'm like, you're just dropping money into the boarding of the animals and like the daycare situation. You don't have to spend a ton of time working out. Do you? I'll bet you don't. Yeah. We, we work out a lot, but that's only like a few hours a day.
它只会，就是，到处飞，而且我的很多朋友和队友都有宠物，我就觉得，你只是把钱扔进动物寄养所和日托中心里去了。你们不需要花大量时间健身，对吧？我敢说你们不用。是的。我们，我们经常健身，但那每天也只有几个小时。
Honestly, our, our hobby really is we're, we're pretty big foodies. So you know, being in Seattle and we spend a lot of time in New York, that's like my idea of a, you know, what do you want to do or like, what's your ideal night? Like it just a really good pre cocktail. If I'm feeling really feisty, I might start with a Manhattan, but I can only have one because those things are like right to your face and then just like a really good dinner and then, you know, the unnecessary stop after dinner, which you never need and you always take.
老实说，我们的爱好其实是，我们都是相当大的吃货。所以你知道，在西雅图，而且我们在纽约呆很多时间，这就符合我对，你知道的，你想做什么，或者你的理想夜晚是什么样的概念，就是一杯非常好的餐前鸡尾酒。如果我感觉特别有活力，我可能会从一杯曼哈顿开始，但我只能喝一杯，因为那些酒劲直接冲到你脸上，然后就是一顿非常棒的晚餐，然后，你知道的，饭后不必要的逗留，你从来不需要但总是会去。
That's the smoking grass part. And listening to the, listening to the rock and roll you kids, yeah, Sean likes to smoke a lot of grass. Yeah, I used to. I can't do it anymore. But you laugh too much. I laugh, I laugh all the time. I'm the easiest audience.
这就是抽大麻的部分，然后听听摇滚乐，你们这些年轻人，对，肖恩喜欢抽很多大麻。对，我以前喜欢。我现在不行了。但你笑得太多了。我笑，我一直在笑。我是最容易被取悦的观众。
So does Rapino make Rapini? I don't like broccoli very much. Rapini is good though. Yeah. And I definitely will drink Pinot Noir till the day I die. So. Yeah. You snuck in there that yeah, yeah, yeah, we work out, but that's only a few hours a
那拉皮诺会吃辣味小卷心菜吗？我不太喜欢西兰花。不过辣味小卷心菜挺好吃的。对。而且我绝对会喝黑皮诺，直到我死的那一天。所以。对。你刚才偷偷夹带了，对，对，对，我们健身，但那每天只花几
day and then you moved on. So can we back up to that? Yeah. What does one do to work out when you're a top athlete? What do you have to do to maintain that much? Yeah. Well, I mean, I start out with. No, Sean, sorry again for Megan.
个小时，然后你就跳过了。所以我们能回到那个话题吗？可以。当一个顶级运动员时，健身都做些什么？为了维持那种状态，你必须做些什么？对。好吧，我的意思是，我一开始会。不，肖恩，再次替梅根向你道歉。
Did you? No, no, not enough for you, Sean. So what are you guys doing to, is it just basic cardio or are you guys, do you're not pushing weight? You know, we're not pushing a lot of weight. We're more in like the, we do a lot of Pilates, actually Pilates. I feel like as you get older, you need to do a little less, but do it a lot smarter. Tell me.
是不是？不，不，对你来说还不够，肖恩。所以你们在做什麽来，这只是基本的有氧运动，还是你们，你们不进行大重量训练？你知道的，我们不做很多大重量训练。我们更多的是在，我们做很多普拉提，实际上是普拉提。我觉得随着年龄增长，你需要减少一点运动量，但要做得更聪明。告诉我。
So a lot of Pilates, a lot of like strengthening of the little muscles, the stretching. We definitely lift weights, but it's more body weight or kind of lighter weight. Will, what are you going to blast today? Is today back and buys? I did. Well, you know, smart ass. Here's what I did. I did a lot of stretching.
所以做很多普拉提，很多小肌肉群的力量训练，还有拉伸。我们当然也会举重，但更多的是自身体重训练或者比较轻的重量。威爾，你今天要练哪里？今天是练背部和二头肌吗？我练了。好吧，你知道的，自作聪明的人。我是这么做的。我做了很多拉伸。
I did some neuromuscular trigger point therapy today for my hips, which is because as you get older, a lot of rubber band stuff I do with the spiky ball, I do a lot of little muscle kind of stuff like that. And I'm getting into, I'm 50, okay? Tell your body though that you're working out a bunch, would you? Well, Megan, we've taken way too much of your time. This has been so fricking cool. Whatever you want to do, if you're running for any kind of office, whatever you're doing,
我今天为我的臀部做了一些神经肌肉触发点疗法，因为随着年龄增长，我用带刺的球做很多弹力带运动，我做很多这种小肌肉群的训练。而且我开始接触，我50岁了，好吧？不过，告诉你的身体你在大量健身，好吗？好吧，梅根，我们占用了你太多时间了。这真的太酷了。无论你想做什么，如果你要竞选任何公职，无论你在做什么，
you've got at least me and I think these two guys as you can announce it here, please announce it here. We will do anything that you ask us to do. You're just so cool and thank you for taking the time and just so much success in everything you do. Not that you need our good tidings, but you got them and yeah, thank you so much. It was an honor to have you on the show. Thank you for doing this.
你至少有我和我想这两个家伙支持你，你可以在这里宣布，请在这里宣布。你要求我们做什么，我们都会照做。你真的是太酷了，谢谢你抽出时间，祝你在你做的每一件事上都取得巨大的成功。虽然你不需要我们的祝福，但你拥有它们，是的，非常感谢你。很荣幸你能来节目。谢谢你做这些。
Yeah, I've always wanted to meet you, so it was really fun for me. Oh, you guys are too sweet, too sweet. We'll have to do this again. Yes, fantastic. And I announced my presidency run. Yeah. Can't wait. Perfect.
对，我一直想见你，所以对我来说真的很有趣。哦，你们人太好了，太好了。我们得再做一次。太棒了。我宣布参加总统竞选。对。迫不及待。完美。
Oh, Megan Rapino, Megan Rapino, Megan Rapino, Megan Rapino, Megan Rapino, Megan Rapino. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thank you guys. Thank you. See ya. Thank you.
哦，梅根·拉皮诺，梅根·拉皮诺，梅根·拉皮诺，梅根·拉皮诺，梅根·拉皮诺，梅根·拉皮诺。再见。再见。再见。谢谢大家。谢谢。回见。谢谢。
Bye-bye. What a rad human being, right? I was so shocked when, I was so surprised genuinely when you brought her on because I really am a fan and what a voice she is, not only in sports, but just in the world. Yeah, and I just hope she keeps that momentum going, in other words, keeps her pulpit, bully pulpit in front of her. When soccer goes away, I'd love for her to still have some sort of high-profile position like politics so that she can keep charging forward with stuff.
再见。多棒的一个人啊，对吧？当我，当你请她来的时候，我真的感到非常震惊，也非常惊讶，因为我真的是她的粉丝，而且她不仅在体育界，在整个世界上都是一个非常有影响力的声音。是的，我只希望她能保持这种势头，换句话说，在她面前保持她的舆论阵地，即权势讲坛。当足球生涯结束时，我希望她能继续担任某种高调的职位，比如从政，这样她就可以继续推动各种事务向前发展。
Yeah, I don't think that, when she retires, that's not going to be the last year here of Megan Rapino. She even knows it about herself, which was really cool, which she said, I think there are certain people and certain personalities who that happens to, that she's got a sort of a bigger-than-life persona. She knows what's right and what's wrong and she's outspoken and she's got that voice and she's got that swagger and all of that shit. It's just dope.
是的，我不认为，当她退役时，那不会是梅根·拉皮诺的最后一年。她甚至对自己有这样的认知，这真的很酷，她说，我认为某些人和某些性格的人就是这样，她有一种超越常人的个人魅力。她知道什么是对的，什么是错的，她直言不讳，她有那种声音，她有那种自信和所有这些鬼东西。简直太棒了。
Yeah. Can I say that? Yeah. The kids are saying it, for sure. They don't say it anymore, Jason. No. They don't. While they're smoking their grass.
是的。我能这么说吗？可以。孩子们肯定都在这么说。他们不再这么说了，杰森。不。他们不说了。当他们抽着大麻的时候。
They're not like, oh, that grass is dope. No. No, she's inspirational and it's so good for young women. Young men. Yeah. I want my boys to listen to her, you know? Yeah. Anybody.
他们不会说，哦，那个大麻真棒。不。不，她很励志，这对年轻女性太有益了。还有年轻男性。是的。我想让我的男孩们听听她的观点，你知道吗？是的。任何人。
We'll get them a subscription to SmartLess. I should, right? Yeah. It's expensive, but worth it. It's worth it. I hope we have her back again when she wins the next World Cup. When's the next big competition for them? World Cup doesn't come around for another year, I think she said.
我们给他们订一份SmartLess的订阅吧。我应该这么做，对吧？是的。虽然贵，但很值。很值。我希望当她赢得下一届世界杯时，我们能再次邀请她。他们的下一场重大比赛是什么时候？世界杯还要再过一年才来，我想她是这么说的。
Three years World Cup is... So I guess the Olympics. Tokyo, which was supposed to be this year. Yep. And that got... So it'll be next summer. Yep. Yep.
三年的世界杯是……所以我想是奥运会。东京奥运会，本来应该是今年。是的。结果被……所以会是在明年夏天。对。对。
Let's go to Tokyo. That would be so fun. And we'll do SmartLess from Tokyo. You heard it here first. But, well, that was super exciting for me because I've always wanted to just even meet her, let alone talk to her. So that was great. Yeah.
我们去东京吧。那会很有趣的。我们将在东京录制SmartLess。你们在这里最先听到的。但是，这对我来说超级兴奋，因为我一直不仅想和她说话，甚至只是想见她一面。所以这太棒了。是的。
That was amazing. Great episode, right? How cool was she? Great. Very, very well done. Very, very cool. Our cool factor's gone up a little bit more. Thank you.
太棒了。很棒的一集，对吧？她多酷啊？太棒了。非常非常精彩。非常非常酷。我们的酷炫指数又上升了一点。谢谢。
Finally. Thank God. Hey, Jason. Bye. Bye. He said it. He said it. He said it.
终于。谢天谢地。嘿，杰森。再见。再见。他说了。他说了。他说了。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。